يا اهلا بكم الى هذه التغطيه الخاصه التي
تواكب فيها العربيه قمم الرياض هذه
الزياره المرتقبه المرتقبه طبعا للرئيس
الصيني شيجن بنج الى العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض التي سيعقد فيها مع السعوديه مع
الخليج مع ايضا القاده العرب ثلاث قمم
تاتي في وقت هام دقيق حساس ايضا كما يصفه
بعض المراقبين في دلالاته الدوليه
الاقليميه والسياسيه والاقتصاديه ايضا
كذلك الكثير من الملفات ستكون حاضره في
هذه القمم كما تابعنا قبل قليل شوارع
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض تزينت بالاعلام
السعوديه الصينيه وكذلك اعلام الدول
الخليجيه العربيه التي سترك في هذه القمم
الرياض ترتب وصول الرئيس الصيني اليها في
هذه الزياره الرسميه التي اتت بدعوه من
العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
الى الرئيس الصيني والتي كما ذكرنا سيعت
فيها ااا القمم الثلاثه السعوديه الصينيه
والصينيه الخليجيه وكذلك الصينيه العربيه
العديد من الاسئله ربما حول هذه القمه في
توقيتها في دلالاتها نحاول ان نناقش اكثر
في هذه القمم الذي يمكن ان تحمله كذلك من
ملفات هنا مع ضيف الدكتور عبد العزيز بن
صقر الباحث السياسي اهلا بك دكتور عبد
العزيز بدايه ما الذي يجعل الرياض اليوم
قبلت للرئيس الصيني لهذه الزياره لعقد هذه
القيمه ايضا
اكيد هذه الزياره خادم الحرمين الشريفين
للرئيس الصيني
تلخص ثلاثه قمم مهمه القمه السعوديه
الصينيه بحكم ان العلاقه علاقه قويه
وكبيره بدات في منتصف الثمانينات وتم
التبادل الدبلوماسي بين السعوديه والصين
في التسعينات واستمرت العلاقه تنمو عبر
هذه المرحله من التسعينات الى يومنا هذا
قويه العلاقه بعد عام 2017 بعد زياره خادم
الحرمين وزياره سمو ولي العهد ايضا الى
الصين
وشاهدت نمو الرئيس الصيني الحالي وهو في
فتره الثالثه حريصه منذ توليه السلطه على
تقويه العلاقه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ومع الدول الخليج عاصمه القرار
الان هي الرياض والكل ينظر الى الرياض
بانها هي المنطقه وهي العاصمه التي يتخذ
فيها القرار المهم اقليميا وعربيا وعلى
مستويات اخرى ثانيه بعضها دوليه
ذكرك ايضا للرئيس الصيني اليوم هو في
ولايته الثالثه تم انتخابه همم في
الاسابيع همم الماضيه وياتي السؤال هنا هل
سيتغير تعاطي تعامل الرئيس الصيني في
علاقته الاقليميه الدوليه في ولايه
الثالثه خصوصا مع منطقه الشرق الاوسط باي
شكل بالعكس هو اعطى اولويه واهميه للعلاقه
مع المنطقه في الشرق الاوسط ولذلك راينا
انه خلال العام الماضي كان هنالك زياره
للوزراء الخارجيه الخليجيين وامين العام
مجلس التعاون وكان ايضا هنالك بحث
اجتماعات ايضا صينيه خليجيه في الامم
المتحده خلال فتره انعقاد مؤتمر همم الامم
المتحده السنوي في سبتمبر فهنالك تحضيرات
وهنالك استعداد وهنالك توقع من الجانبين
ايضا في تقويه هذه العلاقه وزيادتها لان
احنا نعلم انه على مستوى دول خليجي اليوم
هنالك 220 مليار دولار علاقه تجاريه
اقتصاديه في ما بين الصين والدول مجلس
التعاون المملكه الجزء الاكبر منها
والمملكه تمثل اكثر من 17 الى 18% من
استيراد الصين لاحتياجاتها من الطاقه
ولذلك حينما نجد ان 130 مليار من 220 هي
صادرات خليجيه للصين هذا يعطي الاهميه
الاقتصاديه الكبيره ولكنها بقيت معظمها في
اطارها الاقتصادي والتنوع ولذلك تركيز
القمم الثلاثه على التعاون والتنميه
الدكتور التعاون التنميه الاقتصاد هل هي
الملفات التي ستناقش فقط ام ان هناك ابعد
من ذلك في قراءتك لي وفهمك لي ما يحدث من
طبيعه وتغير في العلاقات الدوليه اليوم
وفي النظام العالمي كده الصين عضو في مجلس
الامن الدوله دائمه العضويه في مجلس الامن
ولها اهميتها في القرارات هي في بعض
الاحيان حاولت ان تاخذ مواقف سياسيه اقرب
الى التوازن حسب موجه النظر الصينيه قد لا
تروق لنا في بعض الاحيان ولكن اخذت هذه
المواقف سواء في قرارات العلاقه مع ايران
اقصد العلاقه مع ايران المترا واقصد انها
في بعض المواقف مثلا في سوريا اخذت مواقف
مثل مواقف الروسيه على سبيل المثال ففي
بعض المواقف في اليمن مثلا هي ايدت همم
الهدنه ورحبت بالهدنه ولكنها لست يعني لم
تستنكر الحرب بالوكاله التي يقوم بها
الحوثي على المنطقه عندنا فيها فهنالك
قضايا سياسيه انا متاكد راح يكون لها
اهميتها في البحث وانه اي تطور اقتصادي لا
يمكن ان يكون في هذه العلاقه بدون ما يكون
ذلك التطور في البعد السياسي اذا رات
الصين ان الدول العربيه والسعوديه بالذات
حينما تبنت هذا اللقاء هي ايضا الرساله
اخرى نحن استقبلنا الرئيس المملكه رحبت
بالرئيس ترامب في بدايه توليه فتره حكمه
وارحبت بالرئيس وعقد قمم على هذا المستوى
خليجيا وعربيا ولكن ايضا اردنا ان نؤكد
للعالم ان الصين هي ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في
العالم واكبر تعداد سكان في العالم يعني
حجمها يستوعب ويستحق ان يكون له هذا
التركيز لها اهميته الكبيره ايضا دكتور
جهه السؤال كذلك كيف يمكن قراءه التحولات
تحولات ما بعد هذا الحدث ما بعدها هذه
القمه باول مره تجتمع الدول العربيه هنا
في الرياض نعم باصين تبحث الكثير من
الملفات الكثير ايضا من ربما الملفات التي
وصفتها قبل قليل بانها تتعاطى مع الصين
بطريقه لا تروق مثلا لبعض الدول العربيه
وهو ليست على وفاق معها فا الى اي مدى
سيحدث التحول في هذه الملفات سيطره تغير
ايضا على اي اسعد المستقبل بالتاكيد وزراء
الخارجيه هذا ما سوف يكون تركيزهم في
الحوار السياسي مع الجانب الصيني لان
هنالك مجمل قضايا ونحن نريد مواقف اكثر
وضوحا من الجانب الصين دوله عظمى والدوله
كبيره ليست دوله صغيره لا تتوقع منها
قرارات واضحه ولكن نتوقع منها قرارات واضح
بالذات في القضايا العاجله التي تهمنا في
المنطقه فايضا على سبيل المثال نحن نحترم
العلاقه الاقتصاديه الايرانيه الصينيه ولا
نرى انه هذا من حق كل الدولتين ان يكون
بينهم ولكن التراخي مواقف السياسيه هذا ما
لدي اا يعني ملا يجب ان يكون من قبل الصين
بمعنى اخر نحن نريد مواقف اكثر وضوحا من
الصين اكثر وضوحا مع المنطقه لان نحن
نعاني من السياسه التدخليه التوسعيه
استخدام البعد الطائفي الصيني الايراني في
قضايانا في المنطقه فنريد ايضا استغلال
هذا الجانب من العلاقه الصينيه الايرانيه
القويه لحث ايران على اخذ سياسه اكثر ما
بين هذه العلاقه الصينيه الايرانيه وتوقيع
اتفاقيه شراك ربما تابعتها خلال العام
الماضي والعامل الذي سبقوا ايضا كان هناك
تحضير كبير لهذه
العلاقه اليوم همم هناك توجه الى شراك
استراتيجيه مع الصين مع الدول الخليج
تحديدا مع الدول العربيه كذلك الصين كيف
تستطيع ان تخلق توازنا بين هذه الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه مع الاعداء في المنطقه
يعني بالتاكيد هي يمكن ان تلعب دور وسيط
ووسيط جيد لسيما انها تستمتع او لها علاقه
قويه مع ايران اقتصاديه ولها علاقه قويه
مع دول الخليج فيمكن ان تلعب دور واحنا
استمعنا ان وزير الخارجيه الصيني كان طرح
مبادره حول الامن في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
ربما يتم التطرق لها خلال هذه السياره
بينه وزراء الخارجيه والبحث في اكثر
تفاصيل طبعا دول الخليج كانت تطلع
الاتفاقيه التجاره الحره مع الصين ولكنها
لم تنتهي كامل بنودها في لذلك ربما لا
تتوقع في هذه الزياره وانما قد تكون في
المرات القادمه هنالك تطلع ورغبه صينيه ان
يكون هذا الاجتماع بهذه الابعاد الثلاثيه
ان يكون سنوي فساله في المنطقه همم هنا
وسلا يكون في الصين على غرار بعض القيم
التي تنظمها الصين نحن لا نتدخل في شان
الصيني الداخلي على فكره نحن نحترم
القلقاس الصينيه نحن مازلنا متمسكين
بواحده الصين مثل همم في الدول العربيه
عندها هذا التمسك في فيما يتعلق مبدا
الصين الواحده نحن لم نتدخل في قضاياهم لا
تبث ولا ال ال ال الايجور ولم نتدخل في
الشان الداخلي الصيني في قضايا ولا في
هونغ كونغ ولا في صراع البلاستيك في في
حوله ولا يمكن ان نكون طرف في اي صراع
امريكي صيني في هذا الجانب لانه لنا
علاقتنا المتميزه مع الجانبين ونحترم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الغرب لاي عين
ينظر الى هذه الزياره باي عين يمكن ان
ينظر كذلك الى مخرجات هذه القمه يعني احنا
لنا علاقه استراتيجيه او علاقه شراكه قويه
مع الغرب فيما يتعلق بالبعد الامني
والسياسي ولا يمكن اغفال هذا الجانب نحن
لم نصل المحاصين الى علاقه استراتيجيه على
المستوى العسكري والدفاع والامني او حتى
في بعض القضايا السياسيه في هذا الجانب
ولكنه يمكن ان تتطور مع التطور العلاقه
الذي يحدث به الجانبه قد يكون هنالك بعض
هواجسس لدى الغرب او الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولكنه تبدد بالمواقف الرسميه
التي في عينيها المملكه ودول الخليج
والدول العربيه ان هي ليست بديل الصين
ليست بديل للعلاقه الامريكيه الغربيه
بالنسبه لنا وانما هي علاقه لها اهميتها
تنمو نموا الاقتصادي وتوسعنا هو النمو
ونحو الشرق وليس نحو الغرب الغرب جنب يعني
انه مو عنده منخفض ولكن لمن تجد ان النمو
في الصين السنوي يتجاوز 87% فهي الاسواق
التي اكثر انفتاحا بالنسبه لنا الاسواق
التي يمكن ان يكون فيها شراكات مستقبليه
فيما بيننا وبينهم هم طرحوا يعني الحزام
والطريق وهم يرون ان المنطقه العربيه
المنطقه مهمه في الوصول الى اسواقها ومن
خلالها ايضا الى الاسواق الاوروبيه
الدكتور برايك بهذه الزياره في هذه القمه
هل توجه الرياض فيها اي رسائل همم في هذه
الزياره وباي شكل يعني انا اعتقادي
الرسائل واضحه ان الرياض هي عاصمه قرار
اقليميه العربيه همم يعني والحمد لله رب
العالمين مكانت الدوليه محفوظه ومعروفه هي
ايضا توجه لحلفائها الغربيين انه لا يمكن
فقط يعني ان ان ان ان ان ان ان ان
نقبل بكل شروطكم بكل رغباتكم ولكن لنا
علاقتنا اقتصاديه ولنا ااا هذه التوازي
علاقتنا مع كافه الاطراف يجب ان تكون
موجوده نحن نرحب بالانفتاح على العالم
ونرحب بتوسيع همم
مصالحنا الاقتصاديه وننطلق منها هناك
دكتور من يقول بان الصين وفي علاقاتها
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه ايضا ال- ال-
الواسعه هذا النمو الكبير ايضا همم
للصين حتى وبعد جهه كورونا عاده مره اخرى
بشكل اكبر من قبل ولكن هناك من يذهب الى
ان الصين لها اهداف سياسيه دائما
عميقه في كل تعاملاتها الدوليه هل تتفق
ان تفصل المنافع والمصالح الاقتصاديه
والعلاقه الاقتصاديه عن البعد السياسيه
وجدت في افريقيا على فكره وساهمت في تنميه
في مناطق في افريقيا ولكن ايضا اعتمادها
في افريقيا على المواد الخام التي بحاجه
لها ومنطقه سوق مهمه ايضا سوف يفرض اجنده
سياسيه وهذه الاجنده السياسيه نحن الان
انتقلنا من مرحله القطب الواحد التي كانت
موجوده اليوم كان هنالك اربع سنينوهات
مطروحه حقيقه على مستقبل العلاقه الى 2050
استمرار الامريكيه همم قوه اخرى موازيه في
هذا الجانب تفكك المناطق يعني وحوده الى
مرحله العصور الوسطى ونمو جماعه المسلحه
غير الحكوميه كانت هذه ضمن السنه هذه
المطروحه لعام 2050 ما الذي يمكن يحدث نحن
نرى هنا انه نموه هذه العلاقه التي ترفض
القطب الواحد والتي تريد توازن من مصلحتنا
ان يكون هناك توازن في العلاقه وان لا
يكون لك قطب واحد لانه وجود القطب الواحد
فقط يجعل بقيه الدول تقبل بالاملاءات التي
ما هي مصلحه الخليج الدكتور همم
ان يكون هناك توازن في الاقصاب بين الحرب
بين الشرق ايضا تحدثون عن الولايات
المتحده تحديدا عن الصين صادراتي 68% منها
الى اسيا واسيا بالنسبه لي هي الشريك
الاساسي المستقبل وهي التي تشهد النمو
اوروبا والولايات المتحده لاصبحت هي مصدره
للطاقه ومصدره الغاز فلذلك انا بالنسبه لي
دخل في مرحله التنافس شبه التنافس الان
فيما يتعلق بمناطق الاسواق لكن ايضا بحكم
العلاقه التاريخيه اللي هي من الاربعين
القرن الماضي هنالك علاقه سياسيه عسكريه
امنيه عقيده قتاليه يعني ارتباطنا اي
ارتباط كبير بمعنى اخر لا نستطيع الانفصال
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن مهم
ان يرسل رساله للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
انت شريك وشريك مهم جدا ولكن لنا شركاء
اخرين يجب ان نهتم بهم ايضا ان يكون لنا
علاقه معهم متوازنه ومهمه على مستوى
الاقتصاد دكتور على المستوى التبادل همم
التجاري السعوديه والخليج مثلا يصدرون
ثلاثه ملايين برميل يوميا الى الصين
والسؤال هنا ياتي هل فعلا السياسه تتبع
المصالح الاقتصاديه في التعامل مع الصين
يعني الى الان ما زال علاقه بائع ومشتري
لكنها لم تنتقل الى مرحله بسبب لانه الصين
ما عنده اطماع توسعيه هو عنده اطماع
اقتصاديه هو يطرح خاطئه يعني موضوع الطريق
والحزام ويريد ان يوزع في مصالح اقتصاديه
ولكنه لا يطرح ايدولوجيات للتصدير ولا
يطرح افكار فيما يتعلق بهذا الجانب هو
يحاول ان يركز على هذا البعد ولذلك
التركيز على هذا البعد ايضا يمنح دول
الخليج فرصه جيده سواء في الاستثمار في
الخليج ونحن على فكره اهتمام المملكه ليس
فقط بالبعد الاقتصادي وكذا سمو ولي العهد
الله يحفظه وطرح قضيه اللغه الصينيه في
المدارس وطرح الثقافه الصينيه ايضا يجب ان
تاخذ بانه ما ننسى الصين بلد غني ثقافيه
وغني بشكل كبير جدا ولذلك كلنا سعداء انه
نسمع بجائزه سمو ولي العهد الثقافيه في
هذا الجانب همم الدكتور المنتظر تحقيقه من
هذه القمم في ظل هذه المؤشرات همم
السياسيه
المضطربه احيانا تقوم تكون ضبابيه او غير
معروفه الملامح مستقبلا كيف يمكن قراءتها
ما المؤشرات التي ستعطيها المنطقه بعد هذه
القمم برايك نحن دائما بحاجه لموقف الصين
في مجلس الامن لانه دوله مهمه جدا ولها
صوت واضح ذلك فهذه بالنسبه لنا يعني لنا
في قضايانا المهمه والتي تطرح على المستوى
الدولي يعني ايضا توسع هذه العلاقه
والمشاركه الصينيه في قضايا التنميه
والبنا التحتيه حينما يكون لدينا خطوط سكر
حديد مربوطه وحينما يكون لدينا شبكات
الطاقه الكهربائيه وحينما يكون لدينا
وسائل الاتصال متقدمه سوف تساهم في
التنميه في المنطقه والصيني اليوم لديها
كافه القدرات التي يمكن ان تتطرحها في هذا
الجانب فلذلك انا ارى انه احد النتائج
المهمه هو توسع خطه التنميه ومشاركه الصين
بمشاركه فعليه فيما يتعلق
بربط هذه المناطق يعني انت تعرف في
افريقيا من
موزمبيق الى
انجولا هنالك خط سكه حديد ربط شرق افريقيا
بغربها وهذا خط مهم جدا الان الصين تطرح
قضيه من النيجر والكاميرون للمحيط او من
النيجر الكاميرون الى الى الى السودان عبر
السودان البحر حتى على مستوي دكتور ايضا
مشروع الحزام والطريق الحرير اكثر من 20
مشروع في اكثر من 20 دوله عربيه يستهدفها
هذا المشروع وبالتالي التجاري والطريقه
الاقتصادي الكبير بالتالي الدول العربيه
كيف السعوديه في مقدمتها كيف ستستفيد كيف
ستوام بين خطتها الاقتصاديه وبين ايضا
كذلك هذه الخطه الاقتصاديه التجاريه
الصينيه الواسعه بدات الخطه من عشر سنوات
ونحن نرحبنا فيها ورحبنا ان كل جزء من
التنميه اصل المملكه يعني بشكل يعني رحبت
عن جزء من التنميه خطه التنميه الصينيه
ولذلك بنسبه لان رؤيه 20 30 هنالك قواسم
مشتركه في ما بينها الامداد واللوجستك
والمدن الاقتصاديه قضيه مهمه بالنسبه لنا
هذه الخطوط وهذه المناطق هي بحاجه الى الى
الى مستودعات الى مناطق الى موانئ الى
خدمات الى حتى يتم من خلالها نقل البضائع
ووصولها الى الاسواق المستهدفه بطرق افضل
واسرع واقلت كلفه من الطرق التقليديه
وايضا تتجاوز مناطق التوترات يعني في بعض
الاحيان تضطر ان تمر عبر مضائق مائيه تضطر
ان تمر عبر مناطق بحريه فيها قرصنه وفيها
حدود بريطانيا
الدكتور برايك هل هناك اليوم محددات همم
او مؤشرات مختلفه لفهم هذه العلاقه بين
بكين والخليج اليوم فهم هذه العلاقه كذلك
ما بعد هذه القمه يعني انا العلاقه واضحه
الان وهي في حجمها الاقتصادي الكبير ولكن
مثل ما قلت لك لم يعني لم ننتقل الى البعد
السياسي والدور الصيني فيما يتعلق
بالسياسه المنطق على سبيل المثال مثلا
اصيل لها علاقه جيده وتدعم القضيه
الفلسطينيه ولكن ايضا بعلاقه قويه مع
اسرائيل فيما يتعلق بقضايا الدفاع والامن
والتصنيع العسكري في هذا الجانب فهي حاولت
ان تكون متوازنه في علاقته حاولت ان تكون
قريبه من كل الاطراف نحن ما يعنينا طبعا
هو طرح قضايانا بشكل عادل ونرغب ان يكون
هنالك النظره صينيه اكثر عمقا في فهم
قضايانا وفي الفهم لانه ما عندنا لا اقماع
توسعيه ولا نريد احتلال دوله اخرى بالقوه
ولا نريد ان نفرض هيمنه في المنطقه كل ما
نريد ان يسود الامن والاستقرار والتنميه
في المنطقه دكتور كيف تقرا هذا التوازن
السعودي في علاقته بالالقاب الدوليه يتحدث
عن علاقته بالولايات المتحده يعني علاقته
اليوم بكينا دعوه الى هذه القمه كذلك الى
جمع العرب على قمه واحده كذلك مع الصين
والخليل كيف انعكس على المصالح السعوديه
برايك دكتور المملكه واضحه في علاقات مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه البعض حاول ان
يزاود على هذا الجانب ولكن في قناته انها
علاقه واضحه مرت عبر الرؤساء مختلفين ومره
عبر مدى زمني اقرب الى قرن من الزمان في
في هذه العلاقه نحن نعلم ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه شريك اساسي وحقيقه بيني
وبينها مصالح مشتركه في هذا الجانب لم
نساهم على هذه العلاقه مع الاسف الشديد
هنالك بعض مزايدات داخلي المملكه رفضت ان
تستخدم بعض القضايا التي لنا دور فيها على
سبيل المثال اوبي كلاس رفضت المملكه ان
يستخدم قرار اوبن بلس في المزادات في
الانتخابات المحليه
الامريكيه السنه الداخليه
لامريكان هم يقررون اي الاحزاب يريدون ان
يحكموا ايها الاحزاب يريدون ان ان ان ان
ان يقدم لهم ما يريد ان يقدم لهم فهنا نحن
ننظر لها بمناظيم مختلفه يهمنا المنطقه
الاسيويه منطقه كبيره اسلاميه كبيره في
الصين يهم لان يعاملون معامله المواطنين
معامله الحسنه مثلهم مثل اخرين ولا نرغب
ان يكون ايجابيات اسلاميه موجوده في اي
بلد صيني تستغل هذا البعد همم الايديولوجي
في اثاره البلبله والفتنه في اي منطقه همم
نرجع ونقول ايضا انه اقليميه العلاقه مع
ايران بنسبه لها مهمه لانه بالنسبه للصين
ترى انه افغانستان والباكستان وحدوده
الخطوط الانابيب والغاز لها اهميه كبرى
ايران لها 17 دوله حدوديه فهي ترى اهميه
في هذا الجانب لكن لا تستطيع الصين اغفال
دول مستقره في علاقتها معها لم تتعرض
العلاقات
اليوم الحمد لله رب العالمين اصبحت الدول
الخليج هي المزار اذا هو من الاكس بوي اذا
هو من المونديال واذا هي من القمم الايه
يعني الاستثمار اللي صار اصبح الكل
اصبحت هي هي هي هي هي
ال ال ال ال المستهدفه من دول الكبرى ان
تاتي اليها اشكرك جزيل الشكر لمشاركه في
همم هذه همم وفي هذا الجزء من همم تغطيه
العربيه لقمم الرئه شكرا لك دكتور عبد
العزيز بن صقر الواحد السيا
همم اذا مشاهدينا لازلنا همم نترقب وصول
الرئيس همم الصيني شيجن بينج والذي يصل
الى الرياض في زياره رسميه بدعوه من العهد
السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز سيعقد
فيها كما ذكرنا قمم ثلاث سعوديه صينيه
خليجيه صينيه وعربيه ايضا صينيه سننتابع
معكم ايضا في نشراتنا القادمه همم هذه
التغطيه من هنا من السيتيو العربيه في
المركز الاعلامي المصاحب لهذه القمم